i've got some great news for loki fans
but first do me a favor hit subscribe
turn notifications i am doing this every
day
one wilson himself who plays morbius in
the loki series he is returning for
season two no word yet on when it's
being filmed rumors are saying it might
be this summer but definitely no release
date it is way too early to tell uh he
confirmed that he is returning in an
interview with wired so you know it for
sure is happening and i personally am so
excited about this because i think he
did
just this amazing job in season one
as morbius and the plot twist where we
find out that he himself
was a time criminal originally
was forced to enter the tva
as his punishment
was probably one of the hugest plot
twists in the short six episode season
and
unfortunately we did not see him on a
jet ski at the end like a lot of people
were hoping for i'm hoping we see that
in season two
but
i definitely want to see more of owen in
the mcu he's just brings this sort of
wow factor no pun intended
and again i know a lot of us are hoping
that he does finally say the word
that we've all been wanting him to say
and um let's see what happens i mean
i'm just like everyone else when it
comes to hoping for the best for mcu
projects and ultimately i mean i leave
it in the hands of
those amazing producers directors
writers and everything because
it's
very rare that we do see a project that
most people don't
like again if you haven't already please
do me a favor hit subscribe i am doing
this every day and i'll see you tomorrow